cloud ids detects malware spyware
command and control attacks and other
network-based threats
its security efficacy is
industry-leading built with palo alto
network technology
being cloud native cloud ids is simple
to deploy it's managed
and provides high performance customers
can also use cloud ids to support their
compliance goals
this gives you the ability to detect
exploit attempts port scans buffer
overflows and more
without having to manage the
infrastructure required to host an
advanced ids
all of this is automatically integrated
with cloud logging allowing for alerts
in ui and the ability to integrate your
simsour platform
in order to take appropriate next steps
for your organization
at a high level here's what happens
first we specify a cloud ids
endpoint to direct traffic to vm's
hosting the ids system
then in order to analyze potential
threats we set up a packet mirroring
policy to duplicate and forward packets
into our ids endpoint
there's a lot of flexibility around
which packets get mirrored as users can
specify to forward packets from one or
more subnets
instances with specific network tags or
even select instances by name
the idsbms are then responsible for
analyzing and managing the threats that
come into the system
if threats are detected they are logged
into cloud logging and we can
if we choose use bigquery or other tools
to take automatic actions based on the
threats ids discovered
getting started is straightforward in
the ui within your vpc
or virtual private cloud navigate to the
network security cloud ids page and
create a new ids endpoint
we'll give it a name select a region for
it to operate in and on the next page
we'll select the threat levels we want
to be alerted for
once we select create behind the scenes
google cloud will set up vm's the host
ids system
it will set up a load balancer to manage
traffic into it and a bunch of other
useful infrastructure to support
securing your platform
once that's finished which will take
about 20 minutes at the time of this
video
you'll attach a new policy to the
endpoint to define which package you
want to be mirrored
in this case we'll name the policy
enable it and we'll specify a subnet
and we'll mirror all packets from it
this means that any traffic coming into
or out of this range of ip addresses
will be duplicated and forward over
to the ids endpoint we set up previously
to test this out
over in the command line we'll use curl
to send test malware attacks to our
server
back in our cloud ids ui you'll see we
now have a few threats of various levels
populated in our ui
by clicking on a thread i can see more
information about it such as the source
and destination ip addresses
and more additionally you can click view
all threat logs which will open up a new
tab
with the threat logs at this point we
could manually take steps to fix some of
these threats
or just like with any cloud logging logs
we could use bigquery or pub sub to
forward these logs to a sim
to perform additional security response
steps the last thing i want to show
before we go
is the cloud ids dashboard that will
show a high level overview of your
system
including the top 5 threats source
addresses and destination ip addresses
you can click on any of these dashboards
to get more information
this is the power of cloud ids in a
nutshell it allows you to integrate
the functionality of google cloud with
palo alto network's advanced ids
giving you a managed cloud scale
security system that just works
for more information about this and
other security topics be sure to check
out the links in the description for
more information on securing your cloud
using cloud ids